So how would you apply a problem reduction to Raven's Progressive Matrices?
Before we actually talk about how our agents would do it,
we can think about how we would do it. When we are solving a matrix, where do
the smaller or easier problems that we are actually breaking it down into?
How are we solving those smaller problems, and how are we then combining them
into an answer to the problem as a whole? Once we know how we're doing it,
how will your agent actually be able to do the same kind of reasoning process?
How will it recognize when to split a problem in to smaller problems?
How will it solve the smaller problems? And how will it then combine those in
to an answer to the problem as whole? During this process think about,
what exactly is it that makes these smaller problems easier for
your agent to answer than just answering the problem as a whole?
And how does that actually help you solve these problems better?